I said this to you before I'll say it
again I really loved your work on this
series
um and I just want to say thanks you did
a great job thank you so much thank you
so much so I I am curious you I know
you're a Lord of the Rings fan what was
it and I know you did obviously tons of
pre-production you worked a long time
before you stepped on set but what was
it actually like for you stepping on set
for the first time and realizing I'm
going to be directing Lord of the Rings
I you know I have a perfect memory of
that feeling
and it was like after being shooting for
six or seven weeks so I didn't have time
I couldn't find the time to to go
through that through that clinic until
that moment because
it was so demanding every single day of
the shoot that I I didn't have time to
think about it and I remember that we
were shooting
um in front of the elf Street the big
elves tree and I saw that set and and
then some of the extras start to arrive
dressing the the elves suits
and suddenly I realized it's like I'm
shooting the [__] a lot of the Rings
thing you know it's like it was an
amazing feeling that moment but it took
me like weeks to to have the time to
find for that for that moment talk a
little bit about if you don't mind um
deciding on the visual language that you
wanted to use to tell the story how much
were you reading the books and thinking
about the way Tolkien framed it versus
the Peter Jackson in the movies and the
way you wanted to do it well I read the
books again uh the the they were an
incredible help because uh talking is so
detailed uh in every everything that he
describes that it was a great help uh
but also we start to look for for art
like not the movies because we're
talking about a different age so the
movies were not not really helpful it
was more about focusing on Art and I
remember that talking to Kate the
costume designer or or Ramsey the
production designer I reference like
paintings and and movies but not not
Peter reaction movies I remember like
talking about the dwarves I referenced a
lot of tarkovsky movies and and Russian
movies Asian state to okay the costume
designer and she loved all those
references and we used them for the show
but most of them were references the of
all movies or paintings not not recent
movies because we were creating a world
from scratch that had nothing to do with
anything we have seen before you
obviously home the first two episodes uh
and you were not directing episodes
three through eight but was there a
sequence in episodes three through eight
that you wish you could have directed
yeah and lots of them I mean I really
enjoy the show the whole show uh
actually I still one of the sequences of
I think it was episode three because
that that's in the fight in the kitchen
with the orc that was taken from episode
three but I I love that scene so much
that we convinced the shell Runners to
to put that sequence on episode two
um when you were you production you
haven't stepped foot on set it's coming
what are you most nervous about as a
director to pull off with the with you
know filming on set with everything you
had to deal with I mean I I in general
the massive scale of everything you know
and we need to pick that massive scale
into a television schedule you know I'm
glad that Amazon had the ambition to
take television to a place that uh it's
totally different from anything we we
had seen before you know was totally
different from anything we had seen
before but but but but it was very
demanding it was very challenging to
create all those set pieces set pieces
requires time of preparation shooting
and post-production and to feed like so
many only in the first two episodes was
uh something that definitely was um the
most demanding thing in terms of what we
had to do well the other thing is to me
it's it's an eight-hour movie I mean
this this isn't a TV show to me this is
just an eight hour film actually I did a
big big two hours movie it was like it's
like like like shooting a blockbuster
you know like like a big big Hollywood
movie because we had so many set pieces
and so complicated but also to create
those worlds from scratch because there
was nothing before I uh almost anything
before I got there you know so we had to
create that from scratch you know so it
was not only two episodes it was to
create the all those worlds to build up
all those worlds that will need to last
for us for the rest of the season sure
actually so you filmed this in New
Zealand I'm curious how long did you
actually spend in New Zealand were you
working on pre-production before you got
there like what was the time commitment
that you put in to to do the series well
we started to actually we started to
develop the show in Barcelona in my
hometown so I I I sat down there with
the production designer and we started
to create lots of designs there then we
jump in really to LA and then we finally
went to New Zealand it was supposed to
be nine months and because of kovid we
spent there a year in a house
but it was great because at the end that
extra time gave us more time to finish
our work
um and actually like spending code in
New Zealand was hard because we were
very far away from our families but at
the same time Kobe was uh the way they
managed Kobe in New Zealand was
extraordinary so so we were able to keep
shooting while the rest of the world was
in lockdown also New Zealand has the
best dairy products I've ever had so the
ice cream there is incredible yeah I
know I know exactly the the place where
you should go to find the best ice cream
in the world
it's it's crazy down there so you're not
um directing any of season two but
assuming the show comes back for season
three which I'm guessing it will uh do
you have any have you talked to them
about coming back yeah I would love to I
mean the thing is that I've been so so
busy
um shooting a film and that I'm still
working on so it has been impossible to
be to be working with them uh but I've
been in contact with them with all the
actors and I would love to maybe someday
in the future actually you bring up a
society of the snow which is uh your
movie
um when as a fan of yours uh when will I
be seeing this and for people that
aren't familiar with it what is it about
well you know it's a famous plane crash
that happened in the Andes in 1972
um there was this movie from Frank
Marshall alive shot in 1993 but it's a
movie based upon a different book
uh it's been very very a very incredible
experience because we've been working
with uh a cast of newcomers all
Uruguayan and argentinians shooting in
Spanish and with all the survivors in
contact all the time so they were most
they were on set or all the time on the
on the telephone so we were able to
recreate exactly what happened in front
of the camera in contact with them in
the same places that story happens
sometimes so it was uh like like I did
impossible like that it was
extraordinary and I had the chance of
doing that but in a much more aggressive
environment because shooting in the
Andes is one of the most demanding
things that you can imagine do you know
when it might be coming out when will
people get to see a trailer yeah not
really not really we are still working
on on the card uh we started to work on
the music but nope no plans yet for the
release I'm hoping later this year maybe
a film festival maybe I don't know
um I gotta rap but um I think I'm gonna
be seeing you later today at screening
so I will just say uh until later today
thank you thank you thanks man have a
great day